ezra had me intrigued when he said that
you may be working on something or
working on something big
uh and so he nudged me to ask you so i'm
now going to
ask you are you so the thing that came
to mind for me is a new book but it
might
but it sounded like it might be
something else yeah i mean so i'm
working on
a bigger project that i'm really excited
about
um which is looking at the
ways in which um
our safety and this actually grows out
of the last book um
our safety net um uh
was sort of described it was constructed
to be difficult to use
and lo and behold when you had a real
crisis in which people need to use
benefits um or safety net programs
right so ui something like that or snap
um that then it you know the systems
can't contain these people
um and just in general i think that that
the government
uh is dysfunctional for a lot of reasons
but one of the ways in which the
government is dysfunctional
is that um it doesn't have a very good
customer service orientation
uh things like doing your taxes are
really confusing so miserable
yeah why right um we have this
enormously over
complicated health system in which you
have to fight with an insurer
and you have to figure out you know does
your doctor take that or the other
it's horrible and the government is
crucial in that and then you you look at
programs like snap or ui
and they're just a disaster and for this
piece i was talking to some folks who
um work on these kinds of systems in
uh like finland and they were just
horrified that you might wait
three months for ui benefits here it's
like literally unheard of there
and and so um that's that's one thing
that i've really been thinking about a
lot this year
um because i think it's in in a lot of
ways intentional
right we don't want the government to
work very well um
or at least a lot of people i want it i
want it to work well annie
you do historically many politicians
have thought that these should be
punitive
programs that they shouldn't be ones
that are easy to access or to use
and and and it's um you know pretty
paternalistic like
well you know if you're unemployed and
you need help from the state then you
should have to
go to this office and figure it out we
don't want to make it to it's a famous
paul ryan
line right like we don't want the safety
net to be a hammock um
but but i think that that you can kind
of back out and just see
how little administrative capacity the
federal government has at this point
and the states that are administering
federal programs and it's pretty
horrifying and it's a really hard
problem to measure
but it's like very obvious to everybody
who ever interacts with any of these
systems
oh we all heard the horror stories of
people getting busy signals for days and
weeks on end because they're trying to
call their uh state unemployment office
and
the obvious question in my mind was why
the heck you have to call someone to get
your benefits like what is going on here
you know like there should be myriad
ways for you to access those benefits
that do not
involve your uh getting frustrated
dialing in and every time you call and
get that busy signal it's an erosion
in public trust yes you know like we're
we're conditioned
uh to think that things are supposed to
be this lousy
and it's awful uh so you're writing a
book about why
things were designed to be lousy is that
i'm working on a story on it now right
um and and it yeah it's about um
it's about um how it came to be that the
the administration that public
administration became the burden of
individuals instead of the government
because i think that that's functionally
what happened um and i think that
there's
absolutely no reason for it it was a
colleague was asking me
um why is it that unemployment isn't
automatic so as soon as you lose your
job in a layoff you don't just
get unemployment and i was like well
because we've designed it not to be
automatic
like there's absolutely no reason that
it couldn't be automatic
um and the same thing for a lot of these
these programs right like
why isn't it that if you are a parent
with low income who has a new kid that
you don't just
automatically get a payment from the
government to support that kid's
nutrition and to make sure that you have
child care
other countries do that we don't um and
so
i think that this really grew out of
my thinking about this really grew out
of the last book where
where one of the cool things about ubi
is it just vaults over
a lot of these problems um but absent
ubi there are a lot of fixes that other
governments have taken um lots of
updates that other governments have made
um and i think that there's like an
obvious the role of the republicans and
all of this is a little bit more obvious
but one thing that that i think is
especially fascinating
is that it's not like blue states are a
lot better on this front than red states
right um they have a lot of issues with
administrative complexity
um california has had an absolute
disaster with its ui system and people
waiting months and months and months for
benefits and
um the problem is is really systemic and
multi-causal
and it touches all sorts of um programs
you know when you talk to people who are
applying for asylum
or people who are formally incarcerated
and you know um
are still involved in the judicial
system it's all the same thing right
it's just
endless red tape in a really profound
way
this to me is the issue annie that you
me ezra anyone else can just freaking
beat the drum on this stuff because
uh everyone can see that our government
is highly inefficient at delivering
various things
to people and we are conditioned to
think that's the way it it supposed to
be even though it's not supposed to be
that way
and it hamstrings uh the
ability for progressives to effectively
uh both win policy changes and argue
for a bigger role of government in
improving our lives
in my opinion because even reasonable
folks uh can look up and say wait a
minute
like it you know it's like you couldn't
get me unemployment benefits for
weeks or i still haven't gotten them i
mean i hear these horror stories
on twitter all the time where people
like still haven't gotten them and it's
september or whatnot um so we need to
actually start paying attention to the
mechanics like the nitty-gritty
it's one reason why you and i both like
universal basic income because
i thought well if we champion a way to
get value into people's hands then
and it's uniform and it's universal then
we're going to figure out a way to
actually get people that money and of
course if everyone was intending that
money you know you know they'd be like
they'd be like where's my dividend uh
and it ends up
um uh building our capacity to actually
add value in people's lives because you
would have to figure out the plumbing
yeah absolutely um and i think that
there's there's a bunch of win-win wins
here right if things are simple
and automatic you don't need a bunch of
civil servants to administer it
right and you can free the government up
to do other things
um and we actually we there's a ton of
political science
research there's a a really great
scholar at cornell
named jamila mishner and a lot of her
work is focusing on medicaid
and people's interaction with the
political system after
um after receiving medicaid or working
with the health system in general
and and you know one of the things that
comes out of that
is that in many ways interacting with
our government
reduces our interest in and confidence
in government as you put it
and and there's even some evidence that
it sort of dissuades people from voting
and disconnects them from the political
process no way
they're like i want nothing to do with
this exactly and i think that there is
this really
interesting kind of like thought loop
that you get in in which like
public services are terrible and it
erodes your confidence in government
and then it becomes self-justifying
right like why would we want to put any
more administration into this if the
government can't get anything right
and i think that you can look at sort of
positive cases of where the government
does get
stuff right like actually most people
who have medicaid are
pretty happy with it i'm old enough to
remember when the argument about
medicaid was that it wasn't insurance
worth having
but it is insurance worth having and
people actually really like it people
are very happy with medicare
people are very happy with social
security people are very happy with
public libraries for instance
um so like shouldn't we be setting that
standard shouldn't everything be as
efficient and transparent
and non-punitive non-paternalistic as
social security right like this is the
argument for
for ubi but you can you can make other
changes
um to sort of nudge you in the direction
so
one change that i think we don't talk
about very often but i think would be
really good
is that i think tanf which is our cash
welfare program should be eliminated
and replaced with a child grant right
you should not have to apply you should
not have to
um you know meet these really onerous
terrible work requirements
you shouldn't have to interface with
with
a welfare office that in many cases um
might might have some preconceived
notions about you if you if you are a
person with with a kid we should just
give you the help right um and and we
should take away all of
the red tape and the judgment and the
everything that goes with it um
and so i think that that's probably the
clearest case um tanf is a really
unworkable
punitive terrible program um depending
on which state you're you're in
um and and it's also not big enough
right like it doesn't
um actually help enough people poverty
um because it's been capped at this
amount since 1996
the same the same amount gets
appropriated for it every year
um and so big yeah i think as a general
point like making government work for
people
is is not necessarily a focus of our
political system but it really should be
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]
you